[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
hello welcome back my little babies my
nerd babies i'm mt and this is new rock
stars welcome back i'm jessica clements
this is the break room the daily show
that keeps you updated on all nerdy news
you need to know about right now coming
up on the show where the bbw is back you
know tommy titled that that's break room
barbie watch and we are on the hunt
stranger thing spin-off news the
guardians of the galaxy holiday special
updates and miss marvel episode 5 which
i know you guys want to talk about and
we're going to talk about but first let
me introduce angelica trey hello it is i
angelica trey
it's going to be here
you got and yeah everybody say that
they're happy to be back yes this is
erica
i'm happy to be here
hi everyone okay
good you [ __ ]
decoys happy
and i like your water shirt oh thanks
great
thank you
like i said something about this you're
like oh thanks so much
[Laughter]
[Applause]
i had a really fun fact there was one
time on rogue theory where eric voss was
like video gamer and i was like hey
and i was like oh damn yeah oh got
another show's live everyone yeah
uh as as we usually do as you know we
have the reverse swear jar so as soon as
we break a hundred you guys get to
choose who gets the curse at you if you
want or just curse and gel and angelica
just don't curse me please personally
okay
if you guys if you break 100 and vote
for me i'm going to curse and joke out i
know you guys want to see that but first
also i keep saying but first let's get
into the headlines get into the
headlines baby
let's get into the headlines
miss marvel episode five dropped at
midnight um
we're coming back
why would you put this like this on the
teleprompter uh miss marvel episode five
dropped at midnight we're coming back to
it put your questions in the chat just
as a reminder uh james gunn answered a
fan's question on twitter by confirming
that the guardians of the galaxy holiday
special would of course have an awesome
mix
do you think it's gonna be better than
stranger things
i think it has such a cool potential
because it's like holiday themed so
inherently it's got like a vibe like a
tone so it looks kind of like a now
album like now that's what i call
holidays
but it's not sure
it's gotta be like classic rock though
so because yeah classic rock there's
some like elvis holiday hits there's
something like 50s holidays
um it's i think the band was the
waitress the merry christmas merry
christmas
i can see the dance off right now there
it is that would be nice 100 that's
going to be in there oh yeah are you
going to sing it
right now
i said it she's going to do it and then
i'm going to get cursed out
i'm sorry i just have to um in an
interview with the rolling stone thor 11
thunder director taika waititi revealed
that he asked natalie portman to be the
star in his star wars movie portman
politely declined as she had previously
spent seven years filming her role as
padme in the prequels did we forget that
she's padme
i think that and this is i'm so sorry
internet at large uh i think that tyc
has the same experience i do where i go
like yeah star wars you know those three
you just don't you don't ignore i really
really like the ones that i grew up with
and then there's some other ones and
then sometimes there's a tv show so i
think taika might just be like let's
make our first new star wars movie in a
while i don't know yeah i grew up with
the the uh kind of first episode one
three yeah
i mean i had seen four or five six okay
earlier than that but you know some
people grew up with you know and i think
that's the generation thing because i i
remember i saw episode one like in
theaters but i was like eleven yeah so
like it wasn't the formative thing that
watching empire was for my family so we
just replayed jedi and empire so like
the prequels drifted into the obscurity
like i think we saw it once whereas like
the og so i think ty could just you know
the prequels are so meme-able though
they all know they have that
that you know factor and i do love that
they're getting their time in the sun
now like i think it's really special
that like that's generations we're the
suits now like the people that grew up
with those are the producers making the
art so it's interesting that like tyke
is you know like 10 20 years older than
us so he doesn't have the same
attachment so it's not his star wars so
she hasn't done those movies yeah okay
so come on in natalie
went right over and i forgot that's what
happened all those seven years are
completed
rosario dawson says osaka uh show will
be a standalone from rebels saying quote
a lot of people have not seen rebels
it's great for them to have seen it but
we've got a standalone chapter as it is
does this mean the show won't focus on
her search for ezra
do we think it will i want it to i like
but maybe that's just me is am i the
only person that would want that i want
ezra to be i want to approach ezra
because when looking we had to do it for
wikileaks once and i was like oh it'd be
nice to see him again and also her the
relationship i just now she's an adult i
want to see how she feels about
everybody right
i think that's like the goal of the show
is to like get the emotional like you
have more time right so that'd be a
character you'd want to spend more time
getting the emotional resonance for so
i'd want that i'd want that but maybe
he's not going to be in there i just
hear me out star wars
i wanted darth maul in canopy
like i was saying the first start was
episode we did together like i want
spider like mall to be in canada too and
i don't want vader to have his own show
like i want kenobi to be on his own
little adventure i want like a like a
religious allegory for the jedi i want
vader just be a boss and i want maul to
come back all spider leggy there you go
we want spider like that's what the fans
want we want sweater legs
give me eight of those legged freaks
it's time for what you guys almost have
been waiting for uh bbw the break room
barbie watch barbie uh has added
industry star marissa bella to cast in a
mystery role
there's a lot of people in his this is
who she is there's a lot of people in
this a lot of people in this
almost too many
almost too many so many cameos are
coming um we need to make a graphic for
bbw uh break room barbie i don't know if
we want that graphic there are graphics
from bbw on the internet yeah really
[Laughter]
netflix has announced the creation of
the duffer brothers new upside down
studios i wonder if you guys have seen
it look at the logo uh i tweeted that
it's too close to imagine dragon's album
um
can you scroll up a little bit more i'm
sorry um and along with a bunch of other
new projects including a new live action
series adaptation of death note the
japanese manga anime series originally
written by uh sagomi oba
and
illustrated by takashi yabada uh
they
i'll leave my quarrels out of this uh
they've done death note before
and i did not like it
netflix
netflix did a live action one with uh
wolf alex wolfe yeah i i saw that and it
was a comedy it was really fun it was
really crazy
it was very funny i had a lot of laughs
i think my my thing about it is like i
feel like death notes close to a lot of
people so it's like oh you did it like
it's been done and it didn't do it well
and i don't know if i can trust again
but i did love willem dafoe uh he did a
very good job and i i hope they bring it
back it was great yeah it's like a good
opportunity for netflix to be like we
listened we're sorry yes and then like
the duffer brothers are like we know
what to do with the kid theme so like
it's the smart it's a smart and i trust
the duffer brothers enough to i was like
good hands and netflix trusted efforts
brothers enough to throw some money at
it like that's the trick is you get like
the actual like we're not gonna listen
just go and then you like play in that
world because they own both they own the
duffers now with this this imprint and
they own the rights to it so 100 yeah
magic baby i i figured they'd probably
have that trust in the duffer brothers
and the duffer brothers probably don't
want to ruin their streak of amazing you
know shows so i'm sure they're very
confident in this let's see fingers
crossed because we know anime hasn't
really had the best live-action
adaptations so far it's like the new
video game thing we're finding some good
video games with sonic and like songs
and some series
i was trying to think about this you
guys in the chat tell me what live
action anime adaptation you like because
i i was it's hard for me to recognize it
um or harder me to think of any uh but
maybe i'm just my scope is
awesome justin chatwin is goku come on
dragon ball z magnum
cinema yeah there we go avatar yeah
there was only one live action that i
really liked and it was erased but there
was a live-action version i think it was
korean if i remember correctly but they
did it basically the show almost scene
for scene line for lion and so that was
the only one i actually liked
yeah i like speed racer which housekeys
oh yeah
okay
i guess i haven't watched i didn't watch
the livestream it's insane it's like
maximum maximalism like it's like
like you know minimalist film this is
the in the inverse it's just so much at
your color
[Laughter]
oh you guys are right someone said none
can't be done hasn't been done can't be
done thank you guys thank you i needed
that um an original series from creators
uh jeffrey addis and will matthews dark
crystal age of resistance a series oh
these are the shows that they're also
making on top of um
death note and the stephen king uh the
talisman which oh i
you guys i love dark crystal and i love
stephen king and i think he they would
do a good stephen king sorry yeah we'll
go to the next they get the 80s they get
the 80s they got it yeah they get they
get kids and that dark emblem flavor and
they get the 80s so all of these things
are that and that like duffer brothers
wheelhouse wasn't uh stranger things
kind of loosely based off of maybe first
season the talisman because we actually
saw in one of the finale episodes lucas
was reading the talismans
[Laughter]
a new stage play set within the world
and mythology of stranger things oh
that's another thing they're doing um
the live action yeah they're doing it
all the stranger thing uh the
live-action stranger thing spin-off
series for netflix based on an original
idea by the duffer brothers they are
doing everything and they are doing the
most
great good to know we did our headlines
now we're getting into what you guys
have come for our thumbnail um
our miss marvel
it's episode five
i saw two and i was like we'll see
yeah
unlike unlike tommy i'm like okay i'm
literally you guys we have teleprompters
here i am 100
uh will ferrell and anchorman
you're like i won't do this again i'm
going to san diego last night that's
that's four not going to say it um
so
ms marvel episode 5 dropped last night
and we got a ton of kamal's family
history a little bit of healing but
honestly a whole lot more questions that
need to be answered the this episode i
love so much because it got into the
history of the partition which i truly
didn't know too much about until this
show i had to like research a lot and
everyone i encouraged to do the same uh
this along with like moon knight these
are shows i have a lot of history that
we should be looking into um and then
also connecting it to the mcu afterwards
so one of our questions that we need to
know is what do we think of the dodc
wants with an enhanced individuals
because we think that with the ending
sorry spoiler we have the bars up
that
uh the dodc shows up last minute in the
episode right blows up the building
right it was the convenience the drones
yeah the drone
was right it like fell off and
shot through yeah uh so what do we think
they want with enhanced individuals i
got a long range you guys want to go
first i got a whole thing
he's going to steal your guys
i think the dodc is the big overarching
villain that leads to young avengers
because i think the way this ends is
we're gonna see that civil war failed
the legislative side right like we've
seen in the marvel cinematic universe
they tried to make a civil war they
tried to you know make people register
that didn't work because of the events
of civil war i think those same bodies
want to still try to regulate
superheroes they're going to do it the
way by going with younger people so
instead of regulating all people are
going to say like oh if you're under 18
you've got to register as a superhero
it's not safe for you like in the comic
books we've had multiple storylines
where like the youth were the way they
got that law kind of passed and in the
comic books uh kamala gets hurt ms
marvel herself and they call it kamala's
law so why she's in the hospital in a
coma they're literally using her name
against her and her friends they're
saying it's kamala's law you've got to
be registered you got to do this and
that so i think the thing that are going
to bring the young avengers together is
they're going to try to pass this law
probably in she-hulk which is the next
marvel property to come out which is in
august and they're going to try to pass
this thing that makes it illegal to be a
young superhero using her name against
her and the events of this are gonna set
up what's gonna be the overarching story
that is the phase four that people think
is so incongruent okay i agree with you
i have nothing to say that's bad okay
let me say one thing
that's how i say um praise and polish i
i agree but i also think that you're
gonna have such strong ties to she-hulk
i think it's gonna show do we have the
timeline on this whiteboard i hope so
because it was art we made
okay i'll just we'll just guess
i don't know where i'm trying to
remember where she hulk will be on the
timeline but i want like how we had
daredevil show up in um spider-man i
want she hoped to show up in this once
like cameron or that's what i'm thinking
as we try it all in together
dc if you've got a character that's
doing legal you want legal ramifications
for the government entity and you've got
both set up by way of dodc and you it's
fun because it's using stark tech like
those drones start tech and stereo
technologies what all comes back to
abuse of power yeah it works someone in
the chat people in the shower are saying
dod cr3
does that sound like a possible a
possibility or at least i don't think
the entire dodc but one of them you
don't think that i think that main dude
could be because he's definitely out
there being nefarious and he's like dude
i know him
but people want to see john costa there
he
and they're definitely like
a problem and i could see that being the
thing with the screen curl war that's
coming and secret invasion which is next
year yes yeah
i'm so bad i always ask
yeah i feel like oh god
yeah
and she hulk isn't even on here yet okay
so all right all that work for nothing
i'm so sorry john great visual though
um so i i slightly agree um
what so we think that okay i want to
hear from you too too what do we think
the dodc's end game is like what's the
point we have one episode left
where are they gonna get well i feel
like this is gonna be a lot of
it's it's a lot of just like about
control and stuff and i
i get the sense that we're going to try
to tie into maybe some you know captain
marvel stuff so i'm i'm trying to figure
out where everything fits in there um
but now i'm just thinking of of koi's
like whole thing too it also establishes
the idea of of heroes not necessarily as
heroes and that would set the tone for
thunderbolts and that would long game
set the tone for x-men this is all
leading to x-men so you have this one
all we care about is
this is happening we'll talk about it
yeah it's coming
no no no no i'm saying keep going
we're
this is
everyone and people in the chat have
been saying x-men too so we talked about
in the comics how it was the terrigen
miss that like kind of awoken her powers
and everyone in the comics was like
definitely x-men they were mutants um
and so
do you think when she sacrificed herself
to give cameron powers that that could
be loosely tied to the terror gym
come on she was a human that walked into
a thing that was missing and died
it looked too close to it like it looked
too similar to she got merged by this
from yeah it wasn't miss it was
electricity yeah but it was it was and
also okay so
you guys in the chat do you do you agree
with this because i was not
i don't know and i don't think they're
trying to hit it so soon
does that mean she's an inhuman she's in
a human i think what so i don't know
what's the problem
is a new human which is like a variation
on an inhuman and close one now has his
powers yeah and okay and the two add on
to this in the in the comic books
cameron's powers are literally kind of
mimicked of emma frost he's like
yeah
yes 100 so i love that his powers are
just like the same crystals that but and
then that's also what kind of deters me
is that he still has like the same
powers now of kamala without the br
without the bangle which is why i think
she's an inhuman and that's like just
something to hone it i think that's more
of like a tool it's like an antenna yeah
like if you have good eyesight you have
glasses just enhances you i think it's
just an enhancer okay first of all
saying no missed yet jessica it was
missed adjacent no missed it was missed
and i'm getting a lot of so you guys
agree with me or
not you gotta make a poll because i see
a lot of votes can you make a poll
whether or not we think uh dawson
however you want to write it mr domestic
mystery mr nomis do we think this is
actually the terrigen agent to get us to
the x-men or do we think this is just
not well because the x-men are are i
think going to come from the eternals i
think we set up a world where we've
already had like enhanced beings over
hundreds and hundreds of years and i
think that may be in conjunction with
the blip activated x genes because the x
genes are going to have to be very
different than the mist you want it to
be yes exactly you're born with which is
why i think the visual of the mist is
important to separate the inhumans i
think that's the mistake agents of
shield made was we didn't feel as big of
a difference like they couldn't say
mutants so we didn't have the ability to
differentiate them because we're calling
them like marital children back then so
it's important i think that now we can
say mutants and i also think this ties
into like the visual like i talked about
last time that costumes are now more
comic accurate so when you've got things
like this they're gonna look much more
extravagant like our next wolverine's
gonna wear the cowl it's gonna yeah like
100 and i think that you can do more
kirby in humans visuals so i think now's
the time i think it's coming i think i
don't think you're wrong and also it's
it would make sense for like uh
the the future of the mcu to like even
make a subtle nod because it's like we
can always come back to it yeah we can
always come back to it but then i would
just be hate i would be really upset if
they just don't acknowledge it again
either way is najma real is najma really
dead do we think she's really dead i
think she's gone uh she uh crumbled and
her skeleton came all out and i think
there's no coming back from there
we saw the body yeah if you don't see
the body you don't know ghost situation
yeah no she's not coming back and
dancing but is she getting cameron like
that's what i'm looking at
i think she's body jumper
what i don't know i don't know i think
her physical form is gone i think she's
i i think koi's onto something i think
that because in the um comics cameron is
also evil um and i think him i think
he's gonna become evil from two things
one his mom's dead and that's going to
be like he's going to blame commonwealth
yeah he's going to play out for that um
and then two she's going to be
her soul is going to be in yeah
so i think
he still has that anger so i think he's
just he absorbed it i think he'll he'll
have his newfound powers and then he'll
obviously blame her for his mom's death
in this final episode i think but like
or in the finale but
at the same time i think that it was
just kind of like uh what is the energy
can't be
created or destroyed it just sort of
transferred she had to put it somewhere
and i don't know maybe
comrade will now be also like a portal
or something but i i don't know if he'll
be puppeteered i don't know that's just
too creepy for me i agree with that i
don't think she's like my mom is in
you know i don't know
yeah i don't think it's going to be like
a multiverse of madness type body
jumping type thing i think it just she
transferred her powers to him
yeah might get some of her like
nefarious energy but not exactly like do
whatever yeah
a little corrupt him yeah a little bit i
think corrupt is more better than
possessed
good word good word
now you're straight in that line of me
cussing you out very well
um we have someone asking too why was he
still wandering the jail still and i
think it's just because he couldn't get
out he didn't have help
and now he has powers so maybe he busted
out well did he actually get out was in
an alley i thought he was in an alley
when uh he got his powers because we
ended the episode with his mom being
like you can't come with us
and he was like chained
no before he got to the alley where he
got his powers and he did that like
scarlet witch uh sorry the black widow
land
you guys caught that and then he saw his
hand so that
people are thinking he was still in that
tunnel from the last episode but you're
saying he was in a new way i thought he
was in an alley i thought he got out
because they did get out technically
they got to the stairs but she was like
you stay back
you stayed back uh sorry going back to
our questions on hand um and also i kind
of do want to answer this question that
someone presented
um
was oh who's the bad guy of the series
because that's a really hard question i
think it's comrade in dodc um okay good
cause if you look at the way the story's
been built it's all about family and
he's been jealous of her how close-knit
her like the family is like the big
difference between them two is how
attached to her family she is
reluctantly and now she's embraced her
family he was attached through
nefariousness and now he's severed from
family so now you've got the impetus for
villainy
okay you got original family tie yeah
the whole show is about family yeah like
fast and furious
now he's lost his and now he's like john
cena
so he's making more money than everybody
else showing up and everywhere doing a
lot of makeup which is nice guys she's
doing the work no but like i think that
he's going to feel betrayed twice over
because now he's got these powers on his
channel also in marvel they often do
that like your villain is just your
power set and reverse thing so visually
they even work as enemies and then the
do's dc is the overarching phase four
villain i think it's ultimately the dodc
only because i think they're trying to
find the inhumans to do if um if
agent cleary is a scree or a scroll
either way yeah if he's a scroll um or a
bad scroll i want him to be actually
just looking for inhumans to get on
their side before
the crucial yeah the war happens um also
because it's like this entire time
they're just searching for humans do you
think they're gonna put them in jail but
actually they're gonna like use them
well that's what i think like kevin
feige said that we've been planting
seeds all of phase four is consistent we
know what we're doing which i
i don't know why people are like marvel
doesn't know what they're doing like
they built you a 15-year plan but i do
think we're gonna have a lot of scroll
reveals maybe even as soon as comic con
and that's gonna set up secret invasion
which is gonna set up the crease girl
war which i think alongside young
avengers dark adventures and
thunderbolts is the big arc all right
perfect comic con's in like two weeks
yep oh my god i'm gonna be so mad and
not be
it's a lot and there's a lot of content
coming out and something you said
earlier had me thinking uh you mentioned
the thunderbolts
and the dodc might just be trying to
find these young super powered
individuals to try to maybe recruit yes
because we already have what five of
them throughout the other so instead of
like trying to lock them up or register
them i think they're trying to recruit
them just get them primed and ready and
that way yeah cause i'm also hearing
that like in the comic books uh right
now fisk was just the mayor so he had
his own team of superheroes that were
like basically mercenaries that would
totally play in the in the shows and
movies right now if you've got like this
evil super team as being assembled by a
seinfeld girl and like you've got this
whole thing julie louis dreyfus yeah
okay so sorry julia and julian
she's great she's recruiting people so i
do think that was parallel like i think
the young avengers gonna come up same
time thunderbolts are yeah oh beautiful
you guys go ahead in the chat sound off
with any more questions you have for
miss marvel and we will yell them at you
um but now on to our greatest part the
ads
um oh actually these are fun ads you
guys stay
coming up on your rock stars this week
uh after the break room our stranger
things breakdown by whitney van
laningham is going to drop and i know
you guys talked about uh strange things
yesterday and i'm very upset because i
wanted to be there to say who called it
on uh metallica
you called it i was really proud of that
i wasn't like totally i was like okay
it's got to be something in this vein
okay what year was it and i used like my
the only sherlock i got is pop culture
i'm so dumb and figuring out real good
stuff but puppets you
of these series because it also boosted
up kate bush is running up the hill
metallic years ago was also top gun one
we're living specifically in 1986 again
y'all can't get out of the 80s
it it's the greatest decade yup it
birthed most of us maybe we're not going
to age
far from i was born in 2001. there you
go um
[Laughter]
my brain just thought space odyssey and
i was like you're the baby
[Laughter]
uh tomorrow we have the miss marvel
episode if i break down but i is it
tomorrow john
yeah it is tomorrow we have the ms
marvel episode 5 breakdown where we get
really in depth with it friday is our
thor ending explain so spoilers ahoy oh
ho i didn't want to say that
we have our thor love and thunder
explain and also the boys underground
finale with me uh saturday is our thor
love and thunder breakdown so to make
sure you can see store on thursday or
friday and then come back to us and get
the actual breakdown with spoilers in it
from eric boss now it's on to something
that we all
love more than anything
it's mandatory foreign
[Laughter]
i have to scream like tommy um and let
me tell you tommy is much better at this
uh
he he just is he's better than me he's a
good screamer because he plays it for
three play it again
[Laughter]
maybe
he did it again
yeah
tommy
i love you um need you in my life again
in a recent interview if you guys have
been watching this chaotic world in a
recent interview with empire james
cameron did not hold back
talking about internet trolls with the
criticism to uh avatar 2 he says the
trolls will have i get to curse because
it's in the prompter the trolls
i get to the trolls will have it that
nobody gives a [ __ ] and
you guys
hear me on number four
send it
send in some super chats everybody look
away you guys look what send us some
super chats because i need to curse out
angelica
the trolls have will have it that nobody
gives a [ __ ] and they can't remember the
character's names or one damn thing
about what happened in the movie he goes
on and adds then they see the movie
again and go oh excu okay excuse me let
me just shut the [ __ ] up right now so
i'm not worried about that james cameron
is a menace right now yeah
you guys can talk whatever you want
about avatar 2 but i'm i i'm it's coming
five installments
for better
good luck boy
james cameron literally treats every
interview like remember the two highest
grossing films i made them both
[Laughter]
i'm sure he has he also wasn't he like
searching the bottom of the ocean for
stuff
he just takes five years off and he like
does whatever he wants comes back makes
a billion dollars heads out makes five
years whatever he wants
luther he's like i'll figure it out i'll
come back handle it yeah but go off
james go off as much as you want so for
today's mandatory fun we're telling off
the trolls james cameron style baby i
don't need those super chats for you
guys to go off if you don't want to camp
out right now we're gonna give about uh
james cameron's style so we all picked a
franchise we're gonna tell exactly how
like mr cameron himself should handle
their trolls who wants to go first
because i can always go first if you
want an example
i'll go first you want to go first i'll
go first go off james cameron all right
the franchise i'm gonna defend to the
death
is the rush hour franchise yes i said it
[ __ ] you if you don't like rush hour
chris tucker is a masterful genius we
already know jackie chan is the goat
rush r one two three fantastic flawless
movies i don't care that they haven't
aged well and the jokes are offensive
that's part of their charm and i'll
defend them
yes i said it on the internet i said it
with my chest
and we also just glued hundreds now we
got that freedom we just got a fifty
dollar super chat
um
i'm not trying to vote i'm not trying to
say jessica but if it isn't me but do we
get to curse about trolls is that
separate okay so this one you can curse
out someone in the audience okay uh i
can curse out angelica
all angelicas any angelica in the world
uh
just go for it oh no poll just go for it
um look here angelica
i [ __ ] love you i love you most of
the [ __ ] time
of the time you're [ __ ] delight the
greatest [ __ ] i've ever had in my life
i say [ __ ] in a confirmative way
because i am a [ __ ] i'm like hey my
[ __ ] uh hey what's up [ __ ]
hey [ __ ] get over here uh
angelica you make me so goddamn happy
except for when you bleep my [ __ ]
curtains
after this show i'm throwing you through
that glass
hey i didn't i didn't make the rules
there's the pole actually where we're
throwing it through
who wants to go who wants to go next
week i got one you got one uh now i'm
gonna do my franchise in a second sounds
franchise as much as a type of movie but
before i get to the specificity i want
to go broad strokes
[ __ ] trolls because what you're doing is
you're looking at art that thousands of
people put hundreds of thousands of
hours into and you're deciding that it
doesn't line up to what you wanted and
then you're having a problem with it at
the end of the day any movie is a
miracle at the end of the day any tv
show or book or play or anything is a
product of art and love to entertain you
and if you spend what little time on
this earth you have using that to be
negative using that to downplay people
using that to worst of all insult people
that enjoyed it
[ __ ] you so trolls in general i think
there's no place for them i think we've
we've ruined the internet the internet
is a beautiful way to connect and it's
beautiful way to find each other and to
share in bonds of happiness and it's a
way that we can share all information
and entertainment that mankind has ever
developed and we use it to go like [ __ ]
marvel
that's ridiculous it is the most
clear-cut example of how humanity has
failed is when you click on a hashtag so
[ __ ] those people and i hope they find
the happiness they clearly don't have
and i hope they find the hole that they
can fill with the love that they didn't
get from their parents and they can find
whatever they want to enjoy but mine is
fight club
uh fight club is a movie that is got the
worst pr campaign in the world fight
club is a movie where the antagonist is
toxic masculinity and toxic dudes love
it so the people that it's making fun of
don't realize that it's their thing the
movie is in itself written by a gay man
as an outlet to vent his frustration at
not feeling like he can fight or feel
masculine it's a tear down of capitalism
it's a tear down of the very thing it's
meant to be and it's made by a major
film studio they basically got a movie
studio that was making a lot of art that
was the thing it was making fun of put a
starbucks ad in every frame to make fun
of that capitalism and then made the
ending a thing that bros embraced so
much they didn't realize they were the
ones looking into mirror being made fun
of but unfortunately over the last 23
years the wrong voices of support have
made people not realize that's what the
movie is which is a high brow piece of
incredible art masterfully written
masterfully acted massively directed
that should be revered and not
misunderstood fight club is perfect
um
and i know you guys were like ooh that
koi high and now you're gonna
have a downer with me
i'm that cold glass of water when you're
drunk ready for this james cameron rant
uh because mine is for paranormal
activity i'm a horror fan love horror
love scary things honestly this is kind
of like a blanket statement for all the
like all of them like um the conjuring
uh paranormal activity uh the the edward
annabelle all of those right okay
babadoo i'm at the bottom
what was that one
excuse me
it was like it was something something
man but it sounded very
immature some people made memes and it
was like the pee pee poo poo man
does anyone remember this is the guy you
put your cup in king's cup yeah
from the boys
that people memed it so hard i don't
know
someone in chad helped her with the itty
bitty we're not talking about ant-man
and the wasp
man
okay while i finish you guys in the chat
try to
get
okay
sperm all my horror fiends if i was the
director for these movies that's why i'd
say to the trolls
you love being scared we all know
there's a science to being scared you
little [ __ ] and just because it's a
jump scare doesn't mean you're not gonna
[ __ ] enjoy it don't go to your
friends talking [ __ ] about my movies
because you're still paid to go see it
and i know you're gonna steal it as soon
as it drops on netflix look here at
least i can afford my netflix you piece
of crap i'm assuming this is james
cameron i can afford to get my netflix
subscription unlike you so i'm gonna
actually watch it and give people money
oh i pooped my pants because the movie
was so bad shut the [ __ ] up the movie
was really good and also
how are we gonna act like ghosts don't
scare people ghosts are the most
scariest things in movies we all saw
poltergeist you out of your mind if
you're not afraid of ghosts and when he
was walking through the baby powder and
then they woke up to the footprints of
baby powders and impulsive and i posted
guys in
uh paranormal activity
i got chills down my spine because i
happened to my life i wrote it into the
movie so if you got something to say
about my ghost franchise go [ __ ]
yourself james cameron i'm gonna go to
the bottom of the trenches okay let's
see
someone said it's pee pee pooping time
so i don't think people know what you're
talking about it was i swear it was no
it's not babadook it was just out
you've been to this whole school no i
didn't i swear
is it like the snowman
john knows
not the slender man no
because that's because that's a tall man
it looks like akin to babadook i feel
like you're sure it's not a kevin hart
movie
[Laughter]
no all right okay
i'll just go somewhere in the comments
will figure it out all right um
someone's like what did i miss
so much everything
okay
who doesn't love
creature films who doesn't love the more
hammy adaptations of these comic book
characters i think that the og hellboy
movies are amazing 100 okay you have a
character that is dealing with an
internal struggle okay he looks like the
devil he looks like satan and yet he
tries to do good because as what we've
seen from things like miss marvel right
is that good is not what you are it's
what you do and hellboy has to deal with
that struggle and that's a struggle that
a lot of people have to deal with and
it's made by one of the just gods of
horror and creature
del toro so screw all of you hellboy
haters all right we got a main character
here a protagonist that's dealing with
so much internal struggle
fighting for everyone and all he wants
to do is smoke cigars and drink whiskey
and hang out with his cats
so he'll give you guys hellboy was the
first comic book series i like i read
and i did not know that people will hate
on health i didn't know until this
moment the golden army was my one of my
favorite movies i have to defend the
movie every time like that was so good
maybe those people aren't your friends
yeah yeah that was intense they got
something that that whole it's the
trolls
go ahead in the chat you guys and tell
us who you think won this mandatory fun
and who
i just remembered what yours was
starting off strong
and if you can again guess what
angelica's movie is please go off in the
chat about it somebody's writing it
right now
[Music]
i know i kind of know what you're
talking about but i remember it being
like the snowman something's stupid i
can't
art is worth having
art is worth having everyone
oh my god um
floor 11 thunder
ron tomato score ranks among the lowest
rated mcu movies this titan nice little
warriors well you were saying i went off
about this in the meeting and that's why
it's in here um you guys i know that i'm
probably preaching to a choir maybe i'm
not preaching to a choir
we shouldn't take reviewers so seriously
because there's so many movies that you
genuinely know that you love and it
probably gets the worst reviews there
ever is your joy can't be measured in
other people's reviews if we
i i this might be a fighting sentence
but in what it's been a long time since
uh we agreed with large people making a
consensus for everybody correct am i
right on my own yeah exactly we
shouldn't be uh taking reviewers so
seriously thor 11 thunder was one of my
favorite movies because i love thor and
i loved thor ragnarok and i felt like
this was the ragnarok just more
emotional so i love the gripping it had
on me and they see that people are like
this gets a 60 or whatever what have you
yeah doesn't turn should not turn you
away from it yeah i know that we're all
mcu heads so we're gonna go see the
movie regardless just for the like sake
of knowing what's happening but you
should go and see it because you
genuinely like the movie uh the movie is
good don't let these reviewers take it
away from you don't let it take away
from us because hey we're all in
hollywood trying to make a living and if
reviews ever like turned up turned you
guys away from us you guys wouldn't know
who we were i think it's really
important to find your voice in a
reviewer right so like find someone that
you identify with most of the time
you're never going to hurt them all the
time but i think looking at a consensus
like you're saying like i don't agree
with the masses much so i think it's
like finding your like the rotten
tomatoes score is like a colorized
version of a black and white photo
they're just making broad strokes out of
a consensus it's literally a pass fail
and then you look at the tomato that is
in color and go like this is successful
or not and that's ridiculous it's art so
maybe find a reviewer or five but not
looking at the consensus because you
don't know what those people's lives are
and then on top of not knowing their
lives it's it's
the people that get the uh the like um
that get to be the critics because
there's the fan reviews and then there's
the critic reviews it's the same with
the like academy awards you have to be
an academy award like person to vote in
the academy awards and the numbers for
that are so drastic and different from
like age to diversity to everything just
people that watch movies people that
just watch tv so you can't follow the
entire consensus following one person is
good like
and also when people give like eric boss
for example when he gives you reviews he
generally tells you like the movie's
great you guys need to go see it so so
many people work so hard for it
remember that we watch the post credits
scenes to see what is there but those
millions of names did a lot of work and
like i i consider critic an insult for
me for like i respect critics but if
someone calls me a critic like oh [ __ ]
that like i'm a hype man i carry that
boombox with the beast boys like i'm
happy with it like i'm in the background
of the music video going like yes yeah
because i want to support art so if
there's a movie i don't particularly
like i can still find things in it i
like and you'll notice i talk about that
but i won't talk crap about a movie
because there's no merit in that for me
yeah so i couldn't be a rotten tomatoes
critic i wouldn't want to be like i
didn't like the third like it's just not
art art is about an experience and if
you don't like art it doesn't make you a
bad or lesser person i just don't
understand sharing your disdain for
something people worked hard to make
happy yeah like critic has a negative
connotation
as a word anyway and like when i talk
about movies i'm like i liked it i
didn't like it i don't say it it sucked
or it was the best thing ever yeah you
don't just write it off because yeah
yeah even things outside of my genre
like i love the black phone i usually
like horror movies because i don't
generally look so good right now but
like
but like that's not usually in my
wheelhouse right like i don't usually
typically koi doesn't like to be scared
because the world's [ __ ] up like i
don't need to put bad stuff
already walking i don't need to put two
hours of darkness in my 24 hours of
darkness living in this one so like i
generally don't put myself there but i
left that movie going like oh this is a
modicum of how i think horror fans feel
like i liked feeling scared i liked the
investment i liked all these things so
that opened me up to something but
because of that movie experience i might
look at other horror movies differently
so it's not fair for someone to ask you
my horror movie opinion if i'm like i
just learned why yeah you know it's new
to me so i know you just watched
stranger things right
it was very scary
but it's the investment of the
characters that a show can give me in a
movie i'm generally like why they're
going upstairs but in a show like i'm
having a time but i think it's important
to find your voice that's what i'm
saying like people don't follow me for
horror because i wouldn't get it yeah
also i see people saying oh what's your
reviews on morbius even in my tweets i
said myself i never will speak for other
people to see a movie i will be like
this is what i thought of the movie and
this is what i felt about the movie also
my biggest like positive review was how
fast the movie was yeah i was like oh my
god it moved it moved
i like that i kind of laughed you know
there were some moments in it where i
was like that's kind of fun
you know what's the physics there that's
cool i'm so connected because i did so
much press sport with sony but i will
honestly tell you it's been it's been
months i have no they're not paying me
to say this i went in wanting a 90s
vampire movie yeah i got it yeah yeah i
didn't get my 90s i walked in i was like
i felt like it was a blockbuster and
then they were at the dvd so i get at
the ages i literally felt like i was
like i'm gonna go put this in a rewind
girl now it's blocking at least we're
talking 90s
but like vibe like i wanted i got it
yeah and to everyone who's negatively
reviewing thor 11 thunder like the
critics it's sitting at a 71 on rotten
tomatoes something like that right now i
thought in our meeting this morning it's
like 67. oh so
here's what we can think i think that
the critics who don't like this movie
were probably struck by lightning
themselves that's why they don't like
this movie and they're just putting that
on they fear the love and the thunder
they fear it yeah
exactly
i think it's important to find your
context and also think like you know
there's going to be people that watch
this later in the non-live chat live
chat's great we love you but the people
that comment later at home they're like
what's the point of talking about movies
if you love everything like that's what
i always get or like why just talk about
it then there's no context or how can i
trust then don't but also do it i get
two hours of happiness every time i
enjoy a movie you get two hours of being
upset i think i won
like every time i leave a movie happy i
had a better day than you finding flaws
so i'm gonna keep living yeah
it's it's more so like okay i like
something i didn't like something why
you know there's usually things you know
part of any piece of art that you're
going to appreciate and maybe you won't
like as much so delve more into it plus
we're all online we all do this we know
too well how
there's always going to be people that
love something that hates something now
and so
i know we're all very very aware of this
so just going into anything i don't
really listen to the haters i don't
always you know listen all the people
that are praising it super hard i go and
i see for myself yeah there's no reason
to yuck anyone's yum so publicly and
like to dissuade
my problem with live-action animes is
deep in something else that we can talk
about offline on twitter if you guys
want to all right um i have a lot of
quotes that's handwritten what's offline
twitter
pigeons
[Laughter]
i'm so angry i use my own blood to write
you a letter guys that uh our discussion
for that was just a quick brief thing
about because i know a lot of people are
seeing it they're they're talking about
it and we just want to make sure that
you're watching stuff and enjoying it
and not taking everyone too seriously
you don't like it that's cool too but
like don't make other people's
experience lesser absolutely uh corey
had the best james cameron rats uh
followed by me which i am very surprised
is it because ghosts scare the poop out
of you
don't scare you out to the tiger forget
about pat may make you worried about his
star wars project right paul 55 of you
guys said not at all because he's great
and he's gonna still make a great
product have you seen all of uh star
wars rebels 67 of you guys that know um
maybe we should all catch up together um
which project are you most excited for
with stranger things uh with stranger
things you guys said strange things spin
off which i agree
i agree and let's get to our chats our
super chats um
paint dimensions and let mandatory fun
begin and curse away we did
we sure [ __ ] did uh chrissy says coyo
which i assume is coy uh i just finished
the 2014 ellis can you read that i can't
read it uh they'll shall we run moon
knight what's your favorite run of moon
knight i'm gonna oh and egyptology nerds
this series is like crack to me also hi
jess
uh i love the shelby run i'm a big fan
of the ellis run as well uh the one
you're describing the lsalvia run is
probably my second favorite run to the
bendis run but there's also a run in the
early 2000s illustrated by finch that is
visually my most moon knight so i think
heart wise the one you're talking about
ellis shalvie uh visually finch and as
far as like what i think is the most
approachable vendors for my top three
there you go here for the cookies um
chrissy i'm not gonna take offense so
you didn't ask me here for the cookies
i'm joking i'm joking
it's a joke you got it uh here for the
cookie said it could never be made now
but blazing oh my gosh
here for cookies we need to talk we need
to talk um
uh it disappeared uh but blazing saddles
still does an amazing job holding a
mirror to society plus the back and
forth between cleveland little and gene
wilder is great uh blazes out was one of
the first um mel brooks films i saw and
it does not stand today it's very
problematic but it is in that nature of
emir to society and talking about i
think it's just so
force front and also by mel brooks that
it's like oh this is very offensive and
it is yeah it is
it's the reason i have a where the white
woman at tattoo on my back
do you what don't
[Laughter]
picked up the whole thing this is right
here
a shock in my eyes
[Laughter]
i said eric
um
who we got here azalea rivera i hate you
did the two clandestine females die or
what i assume so because one touched the
touch of the mist and just evaporated
but i think unlike uh najma they didn't
get to give their powers to their
offspring yes yeah
does that mean that najma is like
clearly uh much more higher i too and
like she was the leader so it felt like
there was a hierarchy maybe she had like
more power in her maybe she got theirs
and then oh and they projected all of
them
i don't know she was also like uh even
back in the day during the partition it
was clear that she was the leader it was
like she was like until tomorrow
that moment made me a little confused
because the the black woman can come
destined like tried to go in and it
vaporized her made her skeleton and then
the the portal kept going so what did it
what was it about najima that she was
like it killed her but that her dying
made it close and she could send her
powers off that's what we're thinking is
that she clearly has some sort of
essence or ability to make sure that
like she could close it herself yeah
because even uh wesh mccall was trying
to close it with her powers and it
wasn't closing right so it was like you
needed her to close it she was a missing
piece and i think that's going to be
absolute the last episode is like we're
going to find out what that was or they
could just leave it we find out later
than humans and stuff like they could
just be a seed of like what happened
there yeah um who else we got we got our
chulo or julio 76 do you think the dodc
has some agents working in secret for
hydra
do you think we're dead
i guess no no one ever i don't know
i mean a corrupt government
yeah there's is exactly a lot of
regulations on january 6th events so i
think there's places that things that
keep running so i do think that there
are elements of hydra we'll see pop back
up and in the comics it pops back up a
lot so i think it'll be bad
perfect shelby on safari
says how
if
oh my god how slash if will the veil
return or will the last episode focus
just on the dodc i need the veil to come
back i said a rogue theory where i was
like they broke open the veil where they
did um i said karachi station but
clearly it could be where they were um
which made it easier to go back and
forth but i want i personally want more
information on the veil than i do the
dodc but they could do the they could do
the two they could the dodc could have
more information on the bail yeah and
just call it quits after that but i
think india dc is palpatine it's long
game yeah it does exist
yeah exactly i don't think the veil is
gonna be introduced in anything else
it's going to carry on whereas the dodc
i think is just an underlying threat so
i think you're going to get both oh yeah
also the greg small would run how did i
forget gray small sorry small that is
the right small wood is have you read
the small wood room i read all the moon
that's why i came at chrissy and said
why don't you ask me
the greatest one that's the one i kept
holding on to for moonlight i was like
it's all small woods run
um and then
i can't choose which one's my least
favorite um and also i wouldn't say it
on here um
so who we got uh neil farrell
farrell girl read that for me
okay uh neil farrell gamble says has
anybody else been under the assumption
we've been viewing an alternate timeline
since end game due to the events of no
way home and multiverse of madness not
originally being part of the sacred
timeline oh
oh that's fun i like that that's a good
theory
would that go with what we were saying
what exactly goes over your thing
because like it also allows for us to
have thor be so different yeah because
think about like the only og we've got
left really is thor yeah black is gone
like you know iron man's gone cap's gone
and thor completely is like you know
he's gone through a walkabout of like
existential crises but that would allow
for that to be an option of taking the
characters i just wouldn't i would would
i be a little frustrated a little bit i
would love them it was all a dream
i'd be oh my gosh uh
[Laughter]
um
that was my last time going to a
premiere uh who else we got ernest
esteban said speed racer is still the
best ever animate a live action
adaptation ever let me get an amen
amen amen okay i was entitled i'm coming
with that yeah also uh well i was going
to say someone said in the chat the new
york star said the chat also explains
earth 616 and earth 1999. so earth 616
is the comic book universe but also
they've been labeling that as the movie
universe lately in the beginning they
labeled it 1999 but if you go back and
watch third dark world which is the
actual first mention of the multiverse
he's got 616 universe written as where
they are
so i got questions yeah i got a question
i don't think there is so much about the
timeline but
yeah we completely
straightened for you marvel but i think
there's some things that they're just
like
it's not that they can but they won't
talk about again they're like oh no
one's going to ask questions and it's
like we made a shirt
what if it's upside down in the corner
but uh look at our chart if we look at
exhibit a yeah
we got a chart we got a shirt
we got a wu water bottle
yeah but we can't stop acknowledging oh
and also for our um
for our polls do you think it was team
missed or not we got 57 saying not not
two not too far um when we'll be seeing
thor love and thunder uh you guys said
opening night which i assume is thursday
yeah thursday at midnight yeah yep
there's a midnight if you're at in l.a
it'll be thursday at like 4 p.m yeah
that's where i'm gonna be if you're in a
late and you want to come see all four
of them i'm hosting all four at the lcap
for nerdist so i'm gonna be there at 6
a.m 4 1 8 a.m thor dark world 10 30 a.m
ragnarok and 1 p.m early early we're
doing love and thunder i'm hosting the
whole marathon oh my god you guys you
get to see coy in real life and throw
artichokes at him
he'll
[Laughter]
oh
she's like ninja
zach
that's how i feel about happening we got
any other plugs we're gonna give the
show before we got head off
follow her on tick tock she's got a
great tick tock yeah after my last time
oh what oh thank you
yeah
oh yeah i do i do have that i don't know
i'm always just throwing out skits and
stuff but i do have a cosplay um that
i'll be doing
based off of thor ragnarok so i'll
probably post that up like
in an hour
in 20 minutes i don't know in 20 minutes
soon today perfect what about you eric
uh follow me on twitter at owusu kid
yeah and then yeah sweet funny things
we're doing handles yeah
yeah okay okay sorry eric you finished
yeah yeah follow me on twitter at usukid
i'm on there
posting jokes and
comments and uh my bleeding heart
liberal takes on things yes
okay i go okay
all right let me get this right let me
straighten this one out okay uh a tray
or angelica tray on pretty much the
platforms
i like how you got prepared for that one
yeah um follow me lulu clemens
everywhere uh watch the boys underground
our finale will be this friday
i look for all of those details and
i don't give you warning stamps but i
should
tell you what scenes to turn away from
because nobody wants to get see an
eyeball get stabbed again make sure to
catch all of the things that are coming
out this weekend um we have the stranger
things breakdown coming today we have
the thor love and thunder breakdown
coming on friday uh and saturday just
make sure you get to watch everything um
because a lot is coming your way and
august is only going to get heavier with
content with all the star wars stuff
heading our way i killed boyfriend is
this friday like it's happening right
now i'm not ready like it's been so good
it's been like a nice two months of like
consistently yeah
i'm so sad but then we got the lord of
the rings coming and then we got games
we got uh house of house dragon yeah
some fantasies some good fantasies
coming down the pipeline august is like
really heavy with tv so it's gonna be
like a lot of a lot of here a lot of
after shows you guys thanks for tuning
in check us out tomorrow i love you